in the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen."
The reading from the Sinoxadion, from May 29th, on which we commemorate the Holy Virgin
martyr, Thaedosia. In the fifth year of Diocletian's great persecution in 307, a young consecrated
Virgin, barely eighteen years old, called Thaedosia and Cessaria in Palestine, went up on Easter
Sunday to the prisoners who had confessed the name of Christ, and were waiting in chains
to go before the judge, and ask them to remember her when they attained the kingdom of heaven.
Soldiers immediately seized the girl and took her before urban the governor. Suddenly, filled
with rage and fury, he ordered her to offer sacrifice. When she refused, she was cruelly
tortured on her ribs, breasts, and abdomen, the torture revealing her very bones. The saint,
however, suffered in silence, and this supernatural state excited the fury of the magistrate even more.
When he exhorted her once more to sacrifice, Thaedosia, giving him a long hard look,
said with a smile her face resplendent.
Man, why have you gone so far astray? Do you not know that I am acting in conformity with my prayers,
having been judged worthy to partake in the lot of Christ's martyrs? Seeing that the people were
beginning to mock at him, urban, unable to subdue her with the harshest tortures, ordered that she
be thrown into the sea. Then he turned to the confessors who had been encouraged by the girl's
resistance and condemned them to the implacable copper mines of Faneo. Through the prayers of our
holy fathers, O Lord Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us and save us.